it's Luke and Katie is getting uh jabbed
in the net obviously she can't stop
talking
she's getting some dust put around her
eyes
and she's getting pins in her hair it's
the get ready with me video you never
knew you needed Luke Bryan narrating
Katy Perry's Glam before American Idol
it'll be fun what we come up with on
Monday Luke and Katie shared this clip
to Instagram Luke attempting to walk
fans through kp's hair and makeup
routine additional hair to the hair
and um now she's as aggressive
she's getting her uh
I don't know what now she's getting her
fingers massaged
and then she's
they did a lot of combing and narrow
hairs up yeah seems safe to say Luke has
no clue what's going on it truly it
truly blows your mind and while he may
not know much about hair and makeup he
does know a thing or two about his
fellow American Idol judges hidden
talent
but she's doing that weird baby doll eye
thing robot I do this pose called doll
eye I can close one eye at a time and
still like maintain all function
look at my eyes
[Music]
yeah back in March Katie shared her
party trick with Vogue I've sat in a
hair and makeup chair for 15 years if
they're putting eyeshadow on this eye
and someone's putting my hair up into a
French twist I want to give notes in
real time she's got one eye shut but
she's still
[Music]
now she's staring at herself doing what
they already did
and adding some paint color to the front
part of her brains now she's clipping
her existing eyelids
and
um
now they are cementing her bang line
down and she's done bangline a for
effort Luke I just try to
always bring the energy up and have fun
as for American Idol on Sunday the top
five contestants battled it out for the
three spots in next week's three-hour
season finale the top five the top ten
can make their careers happen and so the
platform of American Idol is just to get
you exposed ladies and gentlemen I mean
pick any one and go make a career out of
it because right now the follow-up is
the most important thing Colin Stowe
Megan Danielle and Ian tongi made it
through and Lionel Richie told E.T
they've got what it takes to go all the
way the top five they have careers I
mean you could just see it
each one of them has they take off a box
who are they you have the identity
they've got the voice they've got the
entertainment factor it's just a matter
now what you do with it
foreign